rien donc c'est celui qui est encore en
couple dans l'émission et qui s'est
marié aurélien et mathieu c'est lui qui
n'a pas pu se marier qu'à sa partenaire
abandonner l'aventuré ben voila mais
c'est pas grave mais sa rivale grave on
va en parler on va en parler et les
chéris je suis très douloureux déjà de
vous voir tous les deux vous avez qui
fait partie des nouvelles aventures on a
changé
l'aventuré l'expérience allait peut-être
subtop la presse et c'est ce qu'on
montre de nous qui est c'est quoi alors
qu'est ce qui vous dérange
moi personnellement rien ouais bah moi
c'est les montages c'est quoi pourquoi
on fait passer un peu on donne un peu
une image de ce qui n'est pas le reflet
de moi tout simplement donc c'est quoi
l'image qu'on dise et donnez vous alors
hier par exemple j'ai vu qu'on donnait
l'image de moi de quelqu'un de macho de
quelqu'un de d'irrespectueux alors que
ça c'est pas du tout passé comme ça et
c'est pour ça qu'avant hier quand il ya
eu la crise de jalousie de jalousie en
fait ouais c'est vrai c'est un guerrier
il ya juste marianne qui s'exprime à la
fin suite à une dispute
ouais et la production en fait fait un
montage et qui est qu il s insinuer
comme quoi je vais m'en ont pas vraiment
de respect alors que passe de marianne a
laissé une photo de son ex accroché sur
le frigo frigo oui ça c'est vous a
confié qu'elle s'entendait toujours très
bien avec cellex c ça se règle et nous
on a une photo nous de balata vous
aiderai vous savez le cueillir une photo
d'un ex sur le frigo alors je vais vous
dire je n'ai rien à vous offrir le frigo
passion qui n'a jamais voulu m'exprimer
je suis en fait c'est de garder contact
avec des ex quand on fait ce genre
d'expérience moi j'arrive je rencontre
marianne je pense qu'elle n'est pas
passée à autre chose et moi par contre
j'ai fait j'ai fait le ménage avant de
faire cette expérience donc je me suis
dit moi je les fais elle ne fait pas
quand je vais vous dire ce qui m'a plu
là dedans c'est que je sens une
sincérité
bah oui rien bah c'est ça qui est
important mais le mec comme moi il n'a
pas de suggestions juste pour faire le
beau à la télé est ce dire après c'est
encore faire le bois la télé c'est
encore la production qui me donne cette
image après
non merci c'est gentil ça garder pour la
première fois franchement jeunes étaient
scotchés j'avais décidé de réserver des
vrais sentiments mais bien sûr c'était
sa cabane moi j'aime les mecs comme toi
tu vois voilà qui font l'émission
relation triste on se rend alors non
mais cette émission quand elle va faire
on l'a vu mais c'est super positif pour
vous ou peut dire il ya quelqu'un qui
parle non quand même merci
non quand on fait cette expérience on a
fait avec la plus grande sincérité moi
enfin pour ma part je suis papa de deux
enfants je vais pas m'aventurer à faire
une expérience comme celle ci sous
prétexte de juste de me montrer à la
télé ou quoi que ce soit c'est ça parce
qu'il ya des gens aussi qu'ils le font
parfois on a l'impression pour les
mauvaises raisons
et vous c'est ça qui est mais c'est
quand vraiment chercher vraiment l'amour
vrai et qui ont vraiment sincèrement
vraiment je le fais vraiment pour
rencontrer la femme de ma vie
alors quoi les scènes de tension entre
aurélien et et marianne on peut
comprendre
je peux comprendre aurélien mine de rien
c'est vrai qu'il ya la photo
oui de l'ex ou fatou est là la
photothèque sur le frigo
ah non jamais je vais intervenir à kiel
à la fouine photo do mais ça c'est pas
possible c'est vrai mais je voulais vous
dire tel que vous êtes là vous êtes
sincère mais dans l'émission c'est
problématique
ça c'est l'image que vous reflétez moi
par exemple je trouvais que vous étiez
macho l'histoire des valises vous la
laisser sortir les vallées on a une
mauvaise image de vauvert dans
l'émission bien c'est vraiment un nom
mais après lui masque on y voyait même
lieu dès lors quoi voir comment ça se
fait qu'on voit ça tous commencé
simplement on fait là par exemple je
vais faire bref par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé hier il ya marianne qui
s'expriment schiller qui dit que je vais
manquer de respect je jamais manqué de
respect je n'ai pas insulté il n'y a pas
eu de violence comment on pourrait
croire maintenant aujourd'hui avec ce
qu'elle a fait hier
le seul truc qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
a une dispute et en plus sa part d'un
geste déplacé qu'elle a qu'elle a eue
envers moi et suite à ce geste est quoi
le geste c'est un geste déplacé je vais
pas rentrer dans des polémiques celles
d'une interview ce week end un peu et
sans le faire exprès voilà un repas sans
faire exprès mais bon oui c'était un peu
une gaminerie envie de dire et je suis
passé je suis passé sur ça mais là je me
suis rendu compte à ce moment là je ne
s'était pas une personne qui était
compatible sur des trucs comme ça avec
moi et donc la suite c'est que j'ai
remis en cause donc non compatibilité
le travail des experts l'expérience et
je me suis dit non en fait c'est la
bonne personne tout simplement marianne
elle était à fond sur vous regardez non
c'est vrai elle est attaquée de marianne
elle est à fond mais même ça j'ai essayé
de lui faire comprendre que mollo mollo
qu aulas tico tico rien qui me plaît pas
en fait j'aurais il est trop beau c'est
mon mari quoi clairement trop rien voyez
nature en suisse il te fous mais qui se
contrôle pas ses portes elle dans ma
fille
mais clairement oui j'ai pris des
réservations vous avez appris ma fille
du nom
originaux
[Musique]
il est trop beau vous mariez sportif
qu'on imagine des tablettes de chocolat
il trop bon mari il va au score pendant
le voyage de noces pour continuer à
avoir des gros avions
l'ado est bon même plaisir bien sûr que
ça fait plaisir c'est valorisant car non
mais je le comprends dans le côté mollo
quand même pas aller et la tante marie
avec marianne vous étiez compatible à
78%
oui apparemment il y atteler 12 qui sont
restés à 78% en fait c'était pourcentage
j'ai jamais compris vraiment comment il
se basait finalement sur et vous avez dû
passer une validation par les
beaux-frères de marianne très protecteur
dire que vous avez vu que ça regardez et
vous apprendre faux épouse madame
marianne gallo valérie ici présents
rennes 22 juin
moi c'est ma soeur est tous pour
détendre entre frères et soeurs
l'inconnu ça fait peur
je connais pas a me fit au bout
maintenant à les marier
je voudrais vous dire que de toute
manière moi je suis quelqu'un de très
respectueux voilà parce que je sais que
c'est important que les humains comme ça
l'absurde tout va n'importe qui non mais
ne vous inquiétez pas pas peur ça aurait
fait ils sont pas du tout comme ça les
frères de supporters ce pour mis
l'ambiance dans le mariage tout le monde
s'entend aussi celle avantage qui fait
certainement bien sûr bien sûr du
montage qui fait ça je peux appeler du
tout comme ça les frères de marianne
justement ils ont mis l'ambiance c'est
être jaloux vraiment quelle histoire
aussi du fait qu'elle avait perdu un
autre frère il a été recteur voulu
rappeler l'histoire alors il ya une
ponette dilution dans votre aventure à
la base vous deviez chacun vous marier
avec une femme dans l'émission mais au
final seul aurélien s'est marié puisque
votre partenaire mathieu a abandonné
l'aventuré c'est une grosse déception
bon sur le moment oui
sur le moment je m'y attendais pas du
tout après pour avoir évoqué les raisons
avec avec cette cette femme déjà que
jean voulait par la base aujourd'hui je
sais le pourquoi du comment je vais
encore moins du tout donc donc ça a été
une tristesse vous voulez sur le moment
parce qu'on avait ce rêve de se marier à
2 bien sûr et puis de pouvoir fait vivre
tout ça deux avec nos familles avec les
belles familles et puis bon bah ça s'est
arrêté là mais mais sans regret quoi je
veux dire je peux refaire la saison si
je leur ferai avec grand plaisir
normalement je viendrai ça nous avait
trouvé l'amour depuis j'ai pas trouvé
l'amour dans l'arrêté je cherche pas moi
je suis moi je suis comme ça moi je
cherche ça n'a rien de sûr que vous
cherchez j'ai donc peur de tout amour
avec mes enfants pour l'instant je me
recentre un peu sur mon rôle de père
pour les pygmées radio dans la suite
soit il n'y a pas eu pour l'instant
c'est vous êtes on papote on échange
mais voilà j'étais célibataire
célibataire et où aurélien hamelle
[Musique]
la vérité je te sont célibataires alors
je vous en dis rien ne dit rien on veut
pas le foot voilà on va dire mais c'est
vrai que mon avis il me reste un épisode
c'est ça dont on reparlera si on ne fait
rien c'est lui moi je voudrais pas
confondu il voudrait dire un truc sur le
montage parce que ça revient tout le
temps un temps que jean henry céant
gonfle pas ce que je fais sur m6 vous
êtes un nom partout vous êtes en plein
dedans donc tout semble mais importante
pourquoi ils ont gardé ça pour quoi ils
ont pas gardé la pâte je vous jure que
ce que vous dites
à l'arrivée c'est super positif pour
vous et l'émission est super positive et
les frères on le voit mais l'ambiance
par longtemps que vous voudriez mais je
vous assure qu'on aide extérieure ils le
voient c'est un homme en fauteuil et
aucune à qui ces deux lettres où l on me
savais pas ça en fait c'est par exemple
je vais dire une phrase qui étiez chez
les revenus ou jeudi d'après la science
et les experts en effet l'un pour
l'autre et vont couper le d'après la
science et les experts et on a
l'impression que c'est moi qui dit on
est faits l'un pour l'autre et ça change
tout le contexte la fête
alors il ya un truc je voulais revenir
sur un sujet qui a fait énormément
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
setti en top tweets hier toute la soirée
tout le monde en parle et c'est les
régulations dacquois bella cobain un
blogueur qui dit que vous n'étiez
apparemment pas célibataire pendant le
tournage de l'émission sur son manque un
stade
le blogueur explique que la petite amie
de mathieu lorée même accompagner dans
les démarches de l'émission pour se
servir de sa notoriété et faire de la
télé réalité plus tard guillaume genton
vous avez oui alors j'ai recueilli le
témoignage de deux femmes qui affirment
avoir été en couple avec vous avant et
pendant le tournage au regard des
valeurs photo assez de femmes on à jesse
qu'à 31 ans de lyon qui dit avoir été en
couple avec aurélien donc avant le
tournage pendant trois-quatre mois
séparation juste avant le tournage elle
a le droit
motif de la rupture il rêvait de faire
la télé réalité j'en vivrais et
notamment la villa des coeurs brisés je
termine juste deuxième femme cindy 35
ans de cannes j'ai été en couple avec
mathieu pendant plus d'un an et pendant
le tournage séparation après le tournage
le 14 mars 2021 cause de la rupture la
notoriété lui monter à la tête qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez valeur des gens
regardent
je trouve ça triste je vais voilà c'est
je la connais oui je la connais cette
femme
moi j'ai des enfants elle a des enfants
bien sûr je pense qu'à un moment donné
en fait il ya d'autres moyens de se
faire de l'argent ou de faire du buzz en
manipulant systématiquement quelqu'un
parce qu'elle savait que j'allais faire
cette expérience en fait j'ai rencontré
au tout début de l'expérience et je lui
ai dit dès l'instant où j'ai su que je
faisais cette expérience je lui ai dit
je lui ai dit écoute on peut pas
continuer donc j'ai rencontré au début
je dis on peut pas continuer parce que
je suis incapable de janvier sur le
tableau et m'investissant à fond dans
cette expérience
en fait je lui ai dit on a le choix mais
moi je ne conçois pas de vivre avec toi
je l'acceptent entièrement qu'elle m'a
dit je n'accepte en tire bien avec elle
pendant le début de l'émission au nom au
casting 16 ans et voilà on s'est
rencontré en janvier au tout début des
castings à marseille
d'accord donc donc après oui on a flirté
pas de problème j'apporte sauf qu'elle
est non mais lesquels elle était au
courant elle est aux courts tout ça mais
moi si vous voulez elle m'a toujours dit
il n'y a pas de problème on se verra
pour les bons moments on se verra de
temps en temps mais en aucun cas je te
causerait des problèmes par rapport à ça
je vais te laisser hommes mariés par la
suite tu feras tout ce que tu en vois tu
auras envie de faire avec cette femme
et puis voilà mais je pense que c'est
vraiment cool qui maquille my mais
peut-être qu'elle a eu vraiment des
grosses arguments pour moi réagir comme
ça je le vois comme ça et après au final
du cou et dans lequel elle veut me faire
payer ça avec cette vengeance
aujourd'hui alors la question est où je
les adore mois ses jumeaux moi je vous
le dit voilà je les adore si ces
gentilles et ils sont souriants ils ont
voulu venir à quai ils ont participé à
mario beaumier rogard y en a un qui a
trouvé l'amour
on sait pas si c'est sûr ou pas parce
qu'on le sera dans deux semaines mais
s'est marié voilà qu'elle s'est mariée
et y en a ou l'autre elle est partie at
elle prévenu qu'elle allait partir et
puis maintenant il est très heureux il a
des enfants il veut rester célibataire
seulement il ya eu cette affaire
qui a été révélée par un blogueur à quoi
ben qui dit que vous étiez avec
quelqu'un avant de faire cette émission
est servi dans cette émission il faut
être absolument célibataire bah oui si
on va monsieur marié nassau qui allie
battait about com ce pas on allait jouer
au tennis et qu'on avait des jets de
raquette
l'exemple n'est pas bon pourtant fait en
gaieté oui donc on a eu l'art et deux
femmes - et donc de mathieu voilà qui
était avec cette jeune fille c'est vrai
que vous avez été vous avez passé le
casting nous étions en ken mais ça c'est
voilà ça c'est ça c'est bon elle savait
en tout cas je faisais à l'expérience
acariâtre 200% donc voilà me disait
l'accepter quand on se voyait de temps
en temps mais en fait
enfin pour moi dans ma tête c'était
clair ses filets j'allais me marier avec
ma future et avec d'éventuelles
exactions
voilà oui oui bah non mais moi je trouve
pas ça très correct je suis désolé parce
qu'en fait on a plus l'impression que
elle elle était très amoureuse de vous
et que finalement elle n'avait pas choix
et que par amour vous allez c'est parti
c'est le déséquilibre dans le sens où on
peut pas contrôler ses sentiments
la suède accord avec itella est
définitivement et ne vous dit rien alors
je suis d'accord avec vous et je n'ai
pas quitté parce qu'à un moment là à ce
moment là dans ma vie j'étais moi aussi
un petit peu fragile et fragile
exactement donc j'avais j'avais si vous
voulez j'allais chercher un petit peu
aussi ce bonheur qu'on pouvait avoir de
temps en temps aussi avec cette personne
oui à travers ça mais mais sans pour
autant sans pour autant avoir la
sincérité de cette expérience à 200%
l'investir et où l'application que ça
pouvait comprendre ce qui vit n'est pas
convaincu apparemment ces six
initiatives que deschamps qui ment j'ai
trouv attendrissant c'est la manche il a
mené les vraies mais surtout trouver
et la dent dure j'ai dû revenir trouver
attendrissant appétissant c'est la
première fois pour être honnête mais je
regardais cette émission c'est
magnifique j'ai fait mais en fait j'ai
mes mails la file à marignane
elle est quand même subi bien sûr
marianne à la duchère c'est très très
beau comme un dieu bénisse 1 alors moi
vous alors c'est quoi cette histoire est
ce qu'on peut remettre le tableau
guillaume genton il était chez le faire
j'ai trois mois avant le tournage
oui mais m'a dit vous étiez en coup
quand vous avez commencé les démarches à
jeudi se dit ça va ça tient même pas
d'histoires de couples
j'étais en vacances sur lyon je suis
allé sur un site de rencontres j'ai
rencontré cette fille sur un site de
rencontres je lui ai dit que j'allais
participer à un casting donc c'était six
mois avant le mariage était même pas sûr
de faire l'émission j'allais faire un
casting pour une émission de rencontres
je veux juste m'amuser
elle m'a dit ok elle m'a dit viens chez
moi elle m'a dit viens chez moi mais
comme elle a monté son plan elle faisait
des photos elles me disaient non mais je
te kiffe trop bien on fait des photos
tous les deux alors qu'en fait j'ai des
textos ou elle me dit non les photos
c'est que pour moi l'un est en fait bien
voilà ce qu'elle a fait avec les photos
donc en fait tellement manipulé
si je peux juste dire et j'ai vu que
j'avais vu qu'en février et je les ai vu
qu en mars et en mars on échange
d'anneaux d'affinement on savait même
pas si elle avoir le marié au premier
regard cas laisse faire et j'étais même
pas encore au courant si j'avais une
compatibilité
donc en fait à ma juste manipuler tout
simplement angulaire viager avec joue je
voulais dire ouais c'est en fait c'est
je trouve ça même même complètement
ahurissant dans le sens où même moi mon
frère on se dit quasiment tout vol
n'était même pas au courant s'exerçait
savoir si ma mère maintenant qu'ils ont
su satisfaire montée mais qui est cette
ville je connaissais pas cette femme
donc mon frère m'a expliqué après
vaguement dans les grandes lignes j'ai
dit c'est dommage pour toi c'est triste
non plus même paru par rapport aux
photos cc que des photos où on est
allongé au torse nu quand c'est vrai on
fait plein d'autres photos où je sais
pas en val d'or
bien sûr que non mais allongée torse nu
les mots c'est pareil les mots qu'on
emploie j'ai jamais dis ma chérie mon
bébé mon amour comme je suis quelqu'un
quand je suis amoureux d'une fille je
n'ai pas de mal à dire je t'aime ou à
dire des mots comme ça la cgeci je suis
un petit point qui m'a quand même dit
mon chéri pendant la pub j'ai de
l'amitié